what about the covid's turnaround from
facebook now
that covered skepticism in terms of the
origin of it if you had a look at this
yeah oh yeah they're dropping their uh
um
i i this is i think going to be very
revelatory to very many people hopefully
uh and i my i pray uh
every day to loki that this is going to
make some people
realize how duplicitous
uh the overlords are why
well because you know to come in with
global pandemic
you're coming in you're asking we're
going to shut down the earth uh you were
going to shut down any discussion about
certain aspects of this like you should
if you question it we're just going to
lose your social media account which is
something that is something
very necessary for very many people
obviously and now to be like
oh yeah maybe we were wrong it's just
like that's an enormous amount of power
for people to have and to assume that
this power is being used reasonably
or objectively has been demonstrated to
be false
just to show that they don't have
capacity these people aren't
the clairvoyant all-seeing eye that they
really need to be the only way that you
would be able to deploy this sort of a
rule is if you were
omnipotent and you knew i know all of
the facts
and i can make the most educated
decision
but when essentially what you had was
people who
knew more than the politifact and the
fact-checking organizations and facebook
and twitter and such like
and they were penalized as much as i
hate brian rose and i think the guy's a
pleb
uh he has someone like david icon and he
talks about i mean
i think it was 5g lizard people or
whatever for him but
still the skepticism about the origin of
kovid was
true much as it pains me to say that
um but people were penalized for holding
what now
is actually considered to be a plausible
if not a realistic view
and let's also talk about nuance let's
suppose okay it's completely
ridiculously and absurd
and nonsensical that kobut was made in a
lab in china
that is might be factually true but what
is truthful
is that governments and i'm not saying
this would happen or not because i'm
just saying
entities are currently trying to
bioengineer viruses
like that is a broader point that needs
to be addressed rather than the
specificity of this case
so you're doing this baby bathwater
situation where you're saying okay
you can't discuss this even as a
hypothesis but at base
there is a 100 certainty that things of
this nature
are being carried on all over the
country by various governments and you
could easily make the cases something
that's a good thing
if you bioengineer one you can reverse
engineer it maybe your diseases
it doesn't have to be nefarious but what
is nefarious
is to kind of arbitrarily as
mark zuckerberg or as dr fauci uh who's
one individual
draw the line and say not only can you
not discuss this
if you do discuss this this is going to
have great personal consequences for you
when it's something where it's it's not
even a person has a vested interest in
it's not like i'm committing slander i'm
going online and saying chris
williamson's this this and that
and you could see them coming and be
like all right we're not going to have
our platform being used
to spread literal lies that chris did so
on and so forth
these are if there's anyone who should
not be given the benefit of the doubt
it's governments in general and if
there's any one government
that should not be given the benefit of
doubt it's the chinese government
um yeah and there's no recourse either
right you know you
you lose your account or you're locked
out of whatever for x number of
months or weeks the recourse is
having these uh entities be regarded
with increasing skepticism and disdain
and creating alternative pathways to
information flowing
which i think there's an enormous
movement online
from people who are much smarter than
both of us put together to create these
work around so this sort of thing can
happen in future
dude every couple of videos has a
comment from someone
citing a new platform yeah that i don't
know about
that i need to upload my videos to that
i've got a list of them i've kept it
i've kept a list
somewhere it's like five or six other
video hosting platforms well this one
this one's decentralized this one's on
the blockchain
the library's the one i think that
everyone likes or others
told about well look you know there you
go there's three there's three different
platforms that we're talking about
but man i remember the first
conversation that minou had about
anarchism and
what you were talking about was the fact
that how many times do you need to be
hit over the head with a stick
or mistreated by powers that be so that
they show you that they do not have your
best interest at heart
before you start to see that there might
be something you miss here
and i don't know whether this is a quirk
of my personality or whether it's a
british thing i
i think it's maybe both um british i
think tend to be relatively orderly we
haven't rioted as much when things have
occurred that doesn't tend to be the
revolts
um that might be a chronic situation it
might just be an acute one for
roundabout now with the way that the
culture is at the moment
but for the most part we tend to stick
to the rules and i've
tended to respect rule makers and such
like sure but dude
the number of times since our
conversation only at the beginning of
this year
where i see something i'm like okay the
masks slipped again there yeah the mask
slipped again there
and it really is a red pill because once
you've seen it
you can no longer unsee it and you start
to see it more and more and more because
the pattern recognition
begins to kick in right that reticular
activating system is so highly attuned
that you start to think well i'm a
little bit skeptical about that i'm a
little bit skeptical about that and then
you have something as blatant as this
covid's
facebook turnaround and you go well this
is this is just a big billboard
saying we don't know what the [ __ ] we're
doing and we make arbitrary rules
and you get punished when they're wrong
even if you were right
before we knew and we can admit that we
were wrong
but you don't get any sort of recompense
or apology
and at a certain point you you asked
yourself wait a minute why
was i ever under the belief that jeremy
corbyn serkir
nicholas sturgeon boris johnson care
about me
or have my best interests at heart when
they've never even met me or know i
exist
and to expect powerful people to not be
self-motivated
or self-driven makes no sense at the
very least they're not going to be in
that position
if they do not have this hunger for
power because it takes so much work to
get elected
especially at the highest levels so even
as a thesis
it's completely incoherent and
nonsensical now you can make the case
which is
uh i think fairly easy to defend that
their careers will be best served
when the country itself thrives right
it's easy to get reelected when the
economy is booming
it's much harder when things are a
disaster so you they would want to seek
out those policies that
for the country and i do think all those
people do want in general probably
what's best for
and they just have different views of
getting there but to say that they're
entirely
just motivated by service when you see
how they talk
you know is is just bizarre to me thank
you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy peace